and let's hope we get an e4 of course
we're gonna probably gonna get a d4
since we expressed the desire to play an
opening
of course
i had absolutely zero doubts that that
would happen
[Music]
okay fine let's go knight f6
um
i had no doubt that that would happen
wait let me just
sniped yeah
one sec
all right um
so c4 sorry
uh what should we play what should we
play let's play a
let's play budapest let's play budapest
game but it's we've never done this
and i've never played the budapest
myself
but i feel like i know enough theory to
play it at this level so the budapest
gambit is
um
if you compare it to other offbeat lines
is definitely on the more reputable side
it is not
it's not like the england
it's not uh
some crap line which where you're going
just for something gimmicky it's a
pretty legitimate gambit
now there are two lines here there's
knight to e4 which is very very
speculative but also a little bit more a
little bit more juicy
the more reputable line is to my
knowledge knight to g4 which immediately
tries to win the pawn back
let's play knight g4 knight e4 is pretty
much trash that's correct okay knight f3
now
here we have to be very careful about
how we develop our pieces as with all
gambits in the budapest you are going
for rapid development and you're going
for a quick initiative you're trying to
get white into a passive position and
then ultimately go for a king side
attack
so queen e7 is a little bit awkward
that's that's not how you do it i i'm
pretty sure knight c6 or bishop c5 are
the are the two moves
um let me remember
yeah i think knight c6 is the move
knight c6 is the move just trying to win
the pawn back and after bishop f4 we
have this check on b4 that constitutes
one of the interesting lines thank you
uh odd hi hero for the prime
all right so you guys might be very
inclined to play bishop c5 but that move
is not as uh effective as it appears
simply due to e3
uh but bishop b4 contains a very
interesting trap so we develop a tempo
we develop a tempo check
usually white plays knight b to d2
and does anybody yeah the smothered mate
so you guys actually i'm quite impressed
you guys know the line here we play
queen e7
generally white plays the move a3
and after a3 there exists a very very
pretty tactical idea that wins the pawn
back
do you guys know what this idea is what
you notice here is that the queen is
x-raying the king
that means if e5 pawn were gone and the
knight appeared on d3 that would be
checkmate
play knight g takes e5 now of course
somebody of his level would not miss
this kind of checkmate
i think he's going to see it i mean he's
not just going to think for a while and
then play a takes b4 but you never know
this is one of the appeals of playing
these kinds of gambits is you know you
you will win one oh my god
we just lost
whoa this is exactly what we practiced
for exactly what we practiced for
thank you for the fat 10 gift subs
pikachu
okay
um
wow i cannot believe that he actually
went into this that's crazy
somebody
of of his of his level should not should
not miss knighty d3
i don't love winning speedrun games like
this because the instructive value is
very limited
with that being said i have to showcase
all of the lines that we could
potentially play
so this worked like a charm
yeah that's crazy 95 a b 93 now there's
a lot of lines where this kind of
smothered made features and the karo
khan
uh in the karo khan you can do something
similar so
as you guys probably some of you guys
know
um
in in the 97 carl you could play the
move queen e2
and paul karis famously won a game like
this knight gf696
the other famous lion where this kind of
thing occurs
is and i see this kids play this all the
time i think it's the blackburn gambit
uh
the tanksta thank you for the prime let
me remember how it goes so it's bishop
c4 now i think there's knight d4
and if white grabs the pawn after queen
g5 you can get a smothered mate knight
f7
queen takes on g2 attacking the rook
white's already lost
because if you drop the rook to f1
queen captures the pawn
now knight c2 wins the queen but
obviously knight f3 is checkmate
um so in the blackburn
by the way if you face this line we
faced it in the five-minute speeder and
i remember
uh you just want to castle here and then
play d3 and then and then basically play
c3 and trade this pawn off white is a
big advantage
uh so
these lines this is way way too gimmicky
none of my students play this this is
too much
but the budapest is is pretty reputable
it's not even that easy for white to get
an advantage against it if played
properly there is a book on it
i think it's called the
it's by grandmaster victor muscalenko
who's a sort of champion of offbeat
openings he wrote a pretty high quality
book on it
and to my knowledge after bishop before
check so how should white continue here
well
white should simply play
95 95 and now just e3 would defend
against the mate
and get probably a tiny advantage for
white i think generally black takes the
knight and then just goes like d6
you get this kind of position where why
does the two bishops white's got some
queen side pressure
but at the same time black has no
targets and black's development is
extremely harmonious here you get the
bishop on the long diagonal you can get
your rook and this is very easy to play
uh why not h3 to kick the knight off
immediately because
if white plays h3 then white blunders
the pawn on
on e5 well not blunders but white gives
up the pawn uh forcefully and there's no
need for that
um
so my understanding is that
after knight f3 knight c6 no this is all
correct
i don't know what the theory is i i
don't know if knight c3 is a move here
although it does allow black on demand
to to take on c3 and ruin the structure
so i think this is probably good for
black
it is a move i don't know see i i don't
even know the budapest game of theory
myself
maybe a rook c1 here or something like
this
so anyways this is a gambit i do
recommend the downside of playing the
budapest full time
is that white can play knight f3 and
avoid it if somebody knows you play the
budapest they're going to go knight f3
and you need another opening you cannot
play only the budapest because here e5
makes absolutely no sense and then i can
take on e5
so
the budapest is something to play
alongside another perhaps slightly more
reputable opening
um that would be my
advice
okay guys um i do not have time for one
more game however
i
probably will be back later tonight for
some more maybe some more blitz and
definitely a couple more speedrun games
so
i'll try my best now tomorrow
i do have the crypto champs commentary
uh and
that's gonna be a very busy day i'm to
be commentating with botez and i have a
lesson in the morning so it's going to
be a a very long day for me tomorrow i
don't want to go to sleep too late but
uh but um
yeah going to be fun i'll try to be back
later guys
and um
i'll see you guys i'll see you guys
probably later tonight
i won't promise it but i'll do my best
well thanks everybody for the support
really really appreciate it
um the the subs and all of the all the
donors are just awesome
uh so so thank you
and um
i will raid
now let's raid boat says
let's read botez
um
give alexandra and andrea raid
i'll be commentating with alex tomorrow
so i'll see you guys later thanks again
take care goodbye for now
[Music]